okay afternoon members gender item1
Chairman's notices good afternoon and
welcome to this council meeting on
Thursday the second of July 2020
my name is councillor Bob Boyce and I am
the chairman of the Morton District
Council this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of April in response to the Cova
the 19 situation there are a few
housekeeping issues to run through
including our new working practices
which have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the etiquette for this
meeting first of all please could I ask
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphones remain muted and
your video feed off we're not addressing
the council this will reduce background
noises and avoid any unintentional
disturbances the meeting will be hosted
remotely via conferencing software which
allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting whilst
being able to protect themselves and
others and to observe the government's
lockdown measures we we may encounter
some glitches this afternoon so I hope
that everyone will bear with us as we
get used to this new way of working we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak all then invite you at
the appropriate time members are
reminded that apart from indicating you
wish to speak whether you have to leave
the meeting the chanc the chat function
should not be used for any other purpose
members the process this afternoon will
obviously be different and for some
items I may invite each member to
speaking turn therefore I would
encourage all members to keep your
contribution as clear and concise as
possible please when speaking and
referring to the agenda papers please
ensure you reference a page or paragraph
number could I also adore that everyone
is directly connected to a power supply
but nobody drops out during two to two
short battery love and laughs if members
need to leave the meeting at any point
please make this known and use the chat
function to signify that you need to
leave the meeting I will now ask
officers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves mr. Holmes get off
no members push at home structure a
service delivery good afternoon members
pull Dodson director of strategy
performance and governance good
afternoon
Chris Leslie director of resources
afternoon Simon quell - monitoring
officer and I understand Tracy Farrell
is present Tracy Tracy foul and
environmental health
Thank You Tara your last one we know
you're here and mr. mr. Wilson appear
here as well mr. mr. Harmon chairman
good afternoon Jamie I'm mr. Wilson here
for agenda item 12 thank you can you now
carry out the roll call of members to
confirm who is in attendance thank you
you could just confirm your hair please
I started me counselor Bamford please
yes president Tora
Thank You councillor Basinger good
afternoon Tara present Thank You girls
me Thank You council miss Beale present
cancer Brian bo-hee I believe you
Asian thank you cats cats channel please
good afternoon
Tara good afternoon chairman present
council Jack thank you sir
cats a joke councillor Edwards
apologies Khorasan present Cara
Thank You mrs. Fleming present time
cancer free cap prison Thank You
councillor Hawker present councillor
hurt
good afternoon Tara but often in
chairman present good afternoon
Thank You cancer home counselor he'll
listen counselor hole present thank you
yes cancer Jarvis of new terror prison
Thank You counselor case after after me
cancer nagging me thank you
cancer maze present thank you
cats are morally good afternoon presents
cat some ice good often and everybody
mean cats in them yes - Shauna see
yes present Tara thank you and good
afternoon everyone
that's a Siddall here taro good
afternoon everybody cancer stop good
afternoon chairman and tarrano members
and keep cancer stilts present Tara good
afternoon everybody
thank you cancer Swayne
yes present good afternoon thank you
good afternoon cancel mrs. Thompson
present tolerant and cancer miss white
miss white okay that completes the roll
call chairman thank you Thank You Tara a
general item to apologies for absence
yes we've had apologies from cats
labelled capsule of Jurek counts the
skenes and canceled miss white and
cancer dome his advice he will be
arriving a little late
Thank You Jenna Thank You Tara agenda
item 3 declaration of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable peculiar interest other
peculiar interest or non pecuniary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to paragraph
six to eight inclusive of the code of
conduct for members and members are
reminded that they are also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare please use the
chat function and indicate and I will
invite you to speak Tara have we got to
cancel amaze thank you and meter as well
I'm here now and Thank You councillor
darn I just notice today right sorry the
first one was councillor castle mrs.
Chan our Chairman Jonah this is Jonah
Thank You chairman Thank You Tara I wish
to declare non-pecuniary interest in
that I'm also a member of Essex County
Council and that will relate to any
matter on the agenda which may have any
reference to Essex County Council but
most definitely one I will highlight is
agenda item dealing with the air quality
action plan I think that's agenda item
number eight
because obviously that's been done in
conjunction with a six County Council
Chairman Thank You Tara next one
cats Africa Chairman yeah Thank You
chairman with regards to agenda item 12
non-pecuniary interest on a modern
harbor improvement commissioner and also
our sail regularly on the river
Blackwater thank you I know councilor
down and councillor mice councillor maze
please yes good afternoon chairman a
non-pecuniary interesting item eight
which is the air quality action plan as
I settled on the working group I'm
happened am also the ward councillor for
modern north Thank You Durham Thank You
chairman again apologies for arriving
late at the meeting and I also have to
leave at 3:00 p.m. I also apologize for
not wearing a tie but I've just come
from a direct from another meeting and I
have a non-pecuniary interest as a
member of Essex County Council in
relation to the same items as have been
raised by councillor chana Thank You
Terra you say everybody yes everybody
that's asked to speak on this item
thank you we move on to agenda item four
the minutes of the 23rd of June
contained on page three to 14 this is on
a different pack and I know that mrs.
channel wishes to to speak on agenda
item three on first page mrs. chana
Thank You chair know it on the minutes
chairman it's actually page four if I
may
oh I'm sorry I thought it was a
declaration of interest no no on the
minutes I wish to come in but okay
chairman it's the second paragraph
virtually well it says that I did
declare
we interest chairman in relation to
agenda item 10 bread will be project
stage 1 consultation as her property
fell within some of these areas I'm
afraid chairman my property doesn't fall
within some of those areas I believe
what I actually referred to was the
large circle and the bottom of that
circle my property that circle fell
nearby to my property my property does
not actually lie from what I could see
in some of the areas mrs. Chan oh I
understand and I understood your
decoration at the time thank you for
that we're on page 4 page 5 page 5
thank you very much on page 5 it speaks
about the the motion to the council ways
the overall political control of the
authority to reconstitute the joint
standards committee I believe I spoke
about the council ways the overall
political control of the joint standards
committee in order to reconstitute it I
remember you making that clear
thank you page 5 page 6 page 7 page 8
page 9 page 10 page 11 page 1213 I so
move is that seconded thank you the
members wish a vote on this or they
accept these information agree
I then move on to agenda item 4 I'm
sorry agenda item 5 with a public
question we've I can advise we've
received four questions from Judy Lee on
behalf of the modern society in
accordance with the council's public
participation scheme these questions
along with the responses from the leader
of the council have been published as
part of the supplementary pact contained
on pages 15 to 18 and circulated prior
to the meeting
now mrs. sorry Tara and can we receive
the questions and answers or do you
think we need to read them out or have
them read out and the responses read out
and chairman the procedures just
referred to them not being read out by
the questioner in the case of remote
meetings yeah so I think that's it's
it's your it's up to you is to have
whether you want an already out or not
chairman because the screen if that
makes it easier I think counts of the
leader which used to give his responses
Tara so leader thank you chairman or
ordinarily I think we take the questions
as tabled and then I just respond with
the answers but in this particular
instance chairman before I do that can I
just take members to paragraph 3 point 1
and the final power of the final
paragraph in 3.1 a there's a typo there
chairman it should instead of saying
alternations to policy detail it should
say alterations champion thank you very
much for that if you wish to read out
your answers leader chairman I'm happy
to do so but they they they should be
you know they are tabled but I can see
the counselor stamp wants me to read
them out so I'll
I'll happily do that chairman inaccurate
so members will take the before
questions which pretty much on the same
subject as as read so I will now respond
in accordance with paragraph 3.1 in the
report bearing in mind the amendment
that I've just said so in response to
question a the documentation on the
preparation of the renewable energy and
low-carbon policy is already a matter of
public record and is available on the
council's website chairman I'm not going
to try and read that address but it is
in the report from here the documents
that have informed the development in
the district and neural energy and low
common carbon policy can be inspected
included the consultation documents and
committee reports the policy was
considered by the Planning Inspectorate
during the examination in public between
2016 and 2017 an inspectors report was
issued detailing his considerations for
alterations to policy be to children in
respect to question B whilst the council
may choose to now advise it no longer
supports the new station by emotion for
example in 2017 it adopted the local
development plan which advises that the
statutory policy position of the council
is different the policy has statutory
weight in decision-making and the
council cannot just withdraw aspects of
the policies it no longer supports when
it is inclined to the council may feel
that it is inclined to change its
position based on evidence and judgment
but I can only see that it can do that
in two ways by completing a full partial
review of the local development plan
submitted to the govern government and
be advised by a planning inspector that
it is legal and can be adopted which
could take at least three years to pass
through all legal stages by notifying
the other alternative is chairman by
notifying the government intends to
withdraw the whole local development
plan this would result in a policy
vacuum and would mean the council has
very little influence over any other
development on land or land management
in the district the council would also
then be on the radar of the government
for not having an up-to-date oak pan and
could face intervention or some planning
powers being withdrawn in relation to
questions see chairman as set out in the
LDP policy d4
the council will strongly support the
principle of the development of a new
nuclear power station at Grant belong
see this is current policy and until
such time as they all DP be withdrawn or
amended as set out and point B above in
response to question D chairman in
accordance with the counselors
Constitution in rule 13 thorry
members can request a recorded vote on
any motion provided that is seconded and
and chairman can I just say to modern
society that I've said it before the
council is more than happy to engage
with them on any matter and should they
wish any more information and they can
write to mr. Dodson that is the response
to the questions chairman thank you
thank you on to agenda item six
Chairman's announcements I have nine
agenda item seven questions in
accordance with procedure rule six three
of which notice has been given
there have been no questions notified
and the rule six three we go on into a
gender item 8 adoption of air quality
action and we move to agenda item a the
adoption of the air quality action plan
2020 to 2025 found on pages 7 to 148 and
I will call on the leader to present
these items and that's leader yeah thank
you very much chairman first of all can
I just start by thanking Tracy foul and
Tim Savage from aces County Council for
the enormous amount of work they've done
on this and the members that have sat on
the working group um chairman joseffer
before I hand over
for to miss fail to go through the
detail I just wanted to clear up one or
two items that have come tonight and
during the consultation process defer a
statutory consul to you requested that
the clean air zone class should be
amended from Class B to D and members
can find the information about that on
page 51 but I'm sure mr. Fowler take us
through this and I can now I can confirm
chairman this is considered not to be a
significant change and the Essex County
Council support this amendment so they
now subscribe to the plan
Joan I'll hand over to miss Farrell
through you and then I'll come back to
deal with the recommendations thank you
thank you very much good afternoon
everybody and the air quality action
plan sets out the measures that model
can also intend to take to improve air
quality between 2020 and 2025 the air
quality management area or Market Hill
was declared in 2018 when the
assessments predicted that the annual
mean for nitrogen dioxide would not be
met and therefore the local authorities
are required in these circumstances to
produce an air quality action plan
within 12 months and the council has a
statutory duty to monitor and report on
air quality and in exercising this
function must have regard to deafness
technical and policy guidance the plan
has been progressed as part of the
steering group and prior to go into
public consultation between the 6th 2nd
of March and the 13th of April it was
approved by the strategy and Resources
Committee the consultation process has
been undertaken complies with the full
legal requirements and the response of
the stakeholder engagement is in the
appendices so report lays out what we're
going to do and you might want you may
wish to look through the action plan and
you may have some questions in regard to
some of the actions thank you thank you
very much leader you're moving the
recommendations Thank You chairman there
is only one recommend a
at paragraph two in new agenda item 7 I
would propose and and I know that
several members want to speak on this
but I would propose chairman that we
agree this recommendation so that can
move forward with the Essex County
Council transport strategy Thank You
Chan is that second deed second thank
you mrs. Chan our wishes to speak
councilor nun and councilor white
so mrs. China first thank you very much
chairman just a bit being a bit pedantic
on page 19 where it lists who the
members of the working group are I am
one of those and so it's Council of
Lucca and just being pedantic here it
puts down our designations and positions
accounts but also calls us walled
members but I think the W should be in a
capital associate the member on that to
become consistent with the others who
are called went board members I'll just
declare I do sit on the working group as
a mold and district councillor but I am
the county councillor for the division
of mulden and I would say having been at
most of the meetings well nearly all of
them I'd think I would say what good
joint working there's been and how the
plans come forward and thank you to
Tracie who's obviously assisted greatly
on this and also an officer at
Chelmsford and also Essex County
Council's have a office like Katie
Putney I've had quite a few responses
during the time it was on consultation
and approaches for members of the public
which I've Julie forwarded on and I know
that those issues have been considered
Tracy assured even those that those that
are a bit late there has been
consideration to the views expressed by
those public and I'd just like to say
how glad I am that regarding the coab
eid 19 we've got not only 20
mile-per-hour in the high street but
also upmarket Hill and I'm very much
hoping and I have been talking about
this with officers and others
hopefully it may be that that is
something that can be looked at but I do
appreciate the most important thing is
to get the transport strategy done and
I've been given assurances that when
able do to Cove aid that will
start surveys we carried out and
evidence will be supplied which will
give a good illustration of what
measures need to perhaps be considered
and applied and decided on to improve
the situation regarding Malden in terms
of air quality and other issues Chairman
Thank You councillor none thank you very
much as a matter of record and for the
minutes please could Tara please record
that despite Market Hill being fairly
and squarely in my ward and the ward of
councillor Mays North Ward we only
joined this working group by invitation
at the last meeting which was the 24th
of June as such we've had very limited
involvement or input in terms of all of
this paper having said that I personally
would like to thank Traci Farrell for
excellent work in pulling us together
and I certainly support some the
submission that's been being made but I
think it needs to be made clear that our
involvement has been very limited
however I and pencil amazed continued to
receive feedback from the residents of
Market Hill and rather embarrassingly so
far we've had to say well we've had very
limited involvement in this but I think
what's really important is that there's
a clear communication strategy targeted
at those residents informing them
exactly what's going on
it's bird will you make a note of that
request please yeah it's a course
chairman councillor white Thank You mr.
chairman and I'm not on video because
I'm at work and we just say that I'd
like to second the good work taken by
Traci on this matter and but I would
like to reiterate is I have been
contacting and Kevin Bentley and some of
the other county councillors to try and
fast-track this scheme to improve it an
even faster rate so we can tie it into
the high street
the grant that we've received there
because the coronavirus and I have been
asking that it is fast-tracked on but I
haven't really had a lot of response and
from County Council there is something
that I'm continuing to work on because
solution but I'd like to see trials
going in as fast as possible but thank
you very much
councillor Swain tell us why you still
with us yes thank you and number points
P and we need to bear in mind at the
point of this exercise is to deal with
the inequality on market Hill and I want
to be weary of other ideas being
infiltrated if they are not necessary
for that purpose including the ideas
that some people have a
pedestrianisation or one way working in
the high street and we have to bear in
mind the transport strategy in business
there is a major item which might deal
with the whole problem may not be
feasible for the basket and one way
working or whatever and that remains to
be seen
so we need alternative sets of measures
which we can get on with one is the
enforcement of the 7.5 weight load on
market hill we could press ahead with
getting the two eight eight dedicated
two eight eight retrofitted as under
grant and we could see better advanced
signage of directing traffic the number
of things which don't seem to have been
really looked at and in so far and one
is the significant point made when the
modeling was done that a significant
percentage of the pollution was come was
not really generated on market here at
all but was coming in from obviously
from the causeway Highbridge area
so I I think signage in the hybrid area
might help to divert some traffic's
perhaps along Holloway Road and which
people in all the way road may not like
and the second thing is to consider
lights at full bridge it's I don't see
why and extreme measures need to be
taken if we can improve things better
the traffic flow better around the whole
Tesco Blackwater an area and perhaps can
we investigate the idea of a lower limit
than seven and a half tonnes for the
market Hill overall we need monitoring
regular monitoring and up-to-date data
and bear in mind some longer-term trends
that are taking place such as decline in
the use of Diesel's and the introduction
of certain electric cars on and some
major items here it does highlight the
need for attention to possible Park and
Ride sites around a bridge and Morden
this seems to be knit and could be blank
spot in the LDP and we really need to be
looking at bear in mind the scope for
Park and Ride sites in any major
developments the last point and which in
the world medium-term longer term is to
ensure that the out of road of the north
hybrid garden suburb is completed as a
priority to reduce the traffic flow
around a bridge and to get out towards
the hatfield federal road thank you
Thank You councillor Swain before I come
back to the leader to sum up can I ask
miss Farrell if she wishes to respond to
anything that's been said
just hopefully reassure councillor Swain
that this this particular piece of work
had so really focus on the area where
there was an exceedance on the market
Hill so what's really good is that out
of that we've got this mold and wide
plan which we'll look at further afield
so that we needed to really focus in on
that area and moving forward we will
extend that out and also just to really
showing really that there is a lot of
monitoring carrying on an ongoing to
support any further works thank you
thank you now somebody that's coming
after I said I'll go back to the leader
to sum up councillor Siddle you wish to
speak yes thank you very much for
allowing that I just like to give my
feedback in terms of the report that was
presented to strategy and resources in
January I was probably quite a harsh
critic of that report in January and I
know I gave the officer particularly
hard time in the chamber what I would
like to say is I'm really pleased with
the report that's come to council now
and how it's been produced and the
sensible solutions that we're now
looking to implement and to move forward
with Essex County Council Thank You Lee
Thank You chairman and thank you council
very helpful leader would you like to
sum up please yeah thank you very much
chairman yeah I'm grateful for the
comments of all the members and I think
a lot of the comments that were made by
council explained a lot of those we
picked up when we look at the transport
strategy as far as the comments made by
council and none regarding
communications he'll remember from the
working group meeting we had lost that
that was something that was very much in
my for fun and what we're actually doing
chairman is where we're harvesting the
contact details of everybody that's who
lives on Market Hill and to keep them up
today and informed as part of the
communication plans that supports this
project so and hopefully you remember
that and the other members will be in a
comfort zone so that's a good piece of
work for our
because I personally think we should
keep them up today children are I've
actually made the recommendation I
believe in that said I'd ask you to put
the question thank you okay Farah would
you like to call the roll please
members its if you agree the
recommendation it's for if you're
against it's against if you wish to
abstain it's abstaining
Sarah thank you chairman Kuk asset
Bamford piece for you councillor
Basinger or you can sir miss Beale for
you cats a Brian bill or it's the boys
abstain this is Jenna
Thank You Tara for capsule Diaries for
Thank You councillor Edwards for mrs.
Fleming for thank you Casa Luker for
cats the haka 404 cats the helm for cats
the whole cancer Jarvis for the keys for
cats and lacan against cancer maze for
Somali for thank you casa Morris not
enough debate or consultation abstain
councillor none for cancer Shaughnessy
for cancer Sidel for thank you
cancellous step 4
stilts for cancer Swain Oh
Thank You counsel mrs. Thompson oh thank
you and counselor miss white for Thank
You chairman I can empathize give
yourself to that though it's 25 for one
against and two abstaining Thank You
Channing
Thank You Tara that is therefore carried
we now move on to agenda item 9 Human
Resources policies and procedures found
on pages 1 4 9 to 172 leader would you
like to present the report Thank You
chairman I mean this is a very short
report it's just something that we
should have done before but we haven't
for some unknown reasons so it forms
very much part of an update chairman and
I would propose that we agree both
recommendations thank you is that ii ii
ii ii ii ii ii chairman councilor none a
Council of laggin first and then
counselor none counselor laggin I think
you share just a couple of questions
really on three point one with the
summary of key issues its levels
continue to be low and within target
with continuation are supports and
managers and this means the sickness
levels there are no longer a concern and
question that any sickness levels are
actually have no longer a concern in 3.2
there's a mention that the HR sickness
statistics measuring the average number
of days lost time full-time equivalent
to be reported I think that's absolutely
critical I think as a member of the
strategy and resources committee I
support the continuation of such data
because it gives us a barometer as
members on a regular basis of the real
issues that go along with in the staff
and levels at multi district council so
thank you chair that's all I might say
counselor none yes sorry chair on a bit
confused are we commenting on nine and
ten
we're on nine contained on
149 to 179 is about procedures isn't it
knowing his Human Resources policies and
procedures untain is statistics yes
policies and one is numbers yes so on 9
then the issue about adopting hi
the hi procedure could officers tell us
what what evaluation method they've been
using up until now then and I think
counseling and that we've always used
Hayes but mr. Dodson sorry chairman I
was always on meat there yes we have
used hey previously this is an update
around the policy and procedures of hey
so it's the revised job evaluation
policy and procedure these for approval
thank you vision - hi it's not the
adoption of hi again I turn to mr.
Dodson to answer that there's a revision
and not an adoption we're certainly
sorry could I defer to the director of
resources who's tabled this report thank
you Jim
mr. Mosley Thank You chairman so we have
always used hey the revision is in terms
of the processes within the report so
has always been the been used we're
still using hey what's change is
actually we're updating the policies to
reflect the new structure is coming so
it's that that the posi aligns to the
new structure that that's the change
rather than a change to using hey do you
understand you satisfied
well I do understand yes thank you it's
rather confusing though isn't it but
what we're really doing then is we're
adopting a revision to hi
mr. Leslie was sticking with Hank but
obviously the policy had references back
to old structures within our council
just aligning to the new structures so
what where some things were out like job
descriptions or groups of Scripture
yeah the procedure itself has been arise
but the hey based system remains in
place
thank you thank you very much return to
the leader now leader to sum up and put
the recommendations although they've
already been put I'm sorry for you to
sum up grateful for the members for
getting the clarification on the
questions that they've asked terminal I
and I have put the recommendation and
are saying question thinking Tara call
the roll please
again members for for against against
abstain abstain and determine starting
Casa Bamford please Paul thank you caps
the passenger or it can't slip miss
Beale for cancer Brian bill or Thank You
castle boys Stein
thank you cancel mrs. cello or Thank You
counselor miss for thank you very much
councillor Edwards or mrs. Fleming for
thank you that's the Freaker that's the
Freaker for thank you that's the helm
for that's the hull bull Jarvis
for that's the keys for key cancel again
abstain please Tara
Thank You counselor maze for hat Somali
for cats amorous abstain develops cats
lemon for cancer Shaughnessy
ball cancer Siddal for cancer step 4
I also notes and Stevens cats and nuns
and comments Tara not relevant yet still
notes just else Wayne cool Thompson oh
and cancer miss white for a chairman the
results of that vote are 25 for nobody
against and 3 abstentions thank you
Tariq
that motion is therefore carried and now
we move on to agenda item 10 where I've
already got speakers one wishing to
speak human resources statistics found
on pages one seventy three two one seven
four two the recommendations leader
would you like to present the paper
please yeah thank you chair this is a
straightforward recommendation by
officers not to report statistical
information to the strategy Resources
Committee can I open German by saying
that staff welfare as always being a
very very important issue and taken very
seriously by members and I I can
remember my time German when I was on
the overview and scrutiny committee and
I laid a piece of scrutiny which got a
national award for staff surveys and we
got some fantastic feedback for master
in those days but chairman as far as
these recommendations are concerned
Chairman I would propose the council you
okay yeah yeah yep chairman I would
propose that council do not approve
these recommendations and that they are
discounted in favor of three new
recommendations and I'll go through
those slowly so that everybody can hear
them and more importantly and thar can
make a note of them so my proposal is
Chapman recommendation one is all staff
statistics including a summary of exits
interviews being reported to PGA on a
quarterly basis recommendation to
chairman that the process of analyzing
staff sickness is reported to the PGA
Committee and finally chairman that the
terms of reference a PGA Committee are
updated accordingly and Chavan in
summary of that the reasons behind those
recommendations I think is absolutely
tech smell and important that we get
this information to PTA so that they can
understand what the underlying
statistics are of our staff so chairman
those are my recommendations is that I
second that
thank you that's the motion before us
now I have counselors laggin and
counselor none wish to speak councilor
Logan they just wanted to apologize to
members and your staff was speaking on
the wrong agenda but just two questions
later through you chair of why do you
speak out I can't I can't hear you yes
sorry chair I'm struggling at work in a
small cupboard at the moment at times of
the meeting i know the feeling.that on
him yeah small is mine I can promise you
that
and we've been to the meeting anyway and
I just got through the leader the the
new recommendations proposed to go to
the PGA I just want struggling the
thinking behind that too
to remove it from the strategy of
resources just like to ask the leader
the the reason for that just to educate
myself leave if you want to respond to
that now do I mean this is something
that I've discussed with with officers
and with the chairman of PTA and and
this is all around performance so in my
mind it should go to PGA but III see
that the the chairman of the committee
wishes to speak so hopefully she'll
still support me on this thing well
thank you chairman when I'm pleased to
say that the leader suggested amendments
have satisfied my concerns Oh Kerry
thank you thank you Bamford and then
councillor Harker and then we've got a
bit of a constitutional crisis carry on
councillor Bamford Thank You chairman I
just would like if possible if we could
have these revised recommendations
clearly on the screen somehow because my
query is the third part of the
recommendation which I believe cancelled
Fluker said was an update in terms of
reference for the PGA now the pga deal
with performance and if this is
performance then it is rightly should go
to pga but i don't understand why we
need the terms of reference updated um
chairman chairman if I could just come
back on that I think the thinking of
that was really because we've got it
we're going to have to change some terms
of reference because at the moment it's
going to strategy resources so maybe
maybe a better recommendation at three
would be to amend amend the terms
reference to strategy and resources but
I think I'll be guided so I will what
I'll do chairman I'll withdraw
recommendations three and
grateful councillor Bamford on this I
think what it needs to say is that the
terms of reference the strategy and
resources can be updated or hopefully if
I've got it right she'll support that
thank you and I think that I think what
we're doing in effect mr. Kuo will
correct me if I'm wrong is we're
removing from the strategy and resources
this issue and transferring it to PGI is
that correct mr. Kuo
oh that's absolutely right Jamie yes
okay so do members understand that
something to come before you but I just
want to get everybody to understand what
a leader is proposing well it's to do
with that chairman okay carry on
counselor mrs. Turner thank you
well um I perhaps in a slightly
different way in that the performance
yes is HR goes to PGA but is it not the
policy matters of resources etc would
remain with strategy and resources
because that's more policy based so I
see there could be a dichotomy there
anyway maybe
so is there the need to remove it all
wholesale from strategy and resources
whereas policy matters would go there
regarding resources but the actual
performance the statistics the data the
quarterly requirements would naturally
fall within pga and it could reflect
that I guess but yeah does it really
need to highlight it I probably need
help again for mr. Krause but perhaps we
can have something in about and
subsequent amendments mr. Crouch yes
yeah me no I haven't looked at the terms
of reference of the two committees but
it strikes me that it strikes me just
listening to the debate that if policy
is with strategy and
sources which it must be so all HR
issues are with with with strategy and
resources the the performance data will
obviously have implications in relation
to possible policy and so if you divorce
the if you divorce performance from the
policy that strikes me is rather strange
because you then have one committee
dealing with performance but it should
be the performance that indicates that
drives what policy changes should take
place so then you have an effect two
committees dealing with what appears to
me to be the same issue okay but when I
said I'll go back to my constitutional
crisis um thank you mr. Krause and
leader would you like to comment on this
before I bring in counselor Harper and
heard well chairman you know I think the
global thing here is performance and and
we've heard you know we've heard from
the chairman of PTA that she sees this
is performance I see it as very much
performance and I think that's and where
this should sit and of course if if
strategy and resources set policies
that's fine you know they can set the
policy and then PGA can actually monitor
the performance against the policies and
if it's not working they can send them
back or ask SNR to reconsider them but
chairman I might give away at this stage
to councilor BAMF and I know that's
ahead of councilor hurt but I feel that
yeah well I think I think it might be
relevant to this actual issue council
Bamford Behrman Thank You chairman well
I confused about this as well now as far
as I I see it PG ages with performance
and S&R deals with policy that is not
changing so we don't need any terms of
reference changes because
we're not going a PJ we're not dealing
with any policy issues we're dealing
with what's happening with the staff
generally you know are they if they're
sick a lot
then perhaps we need to look at it why
the performance is not happening as it
should be that's how I see it
that's what we're really looking at
we're not looking at changing policy the
I'm advised that the SNR terms of
reference state receive reports on Human
Resources statistics which which is a
present with SNR so if that goes to our
PGI then the terms of reference will
have to be changed for strategy and
resources okay I understand but if they
are having those statistics then are
they being recommended that the policy
changes because of those statistics the
answer probably is no so why are those
statistics going to pick to us an arm so
we only little age so I think I agree
with I agree with with the
recommendations that have been made but
I would say mr. chairman that the whole
point of this report was really to say
that these reports were not going to SNR
that's what the point of it was and
we're saying yes they should still go
somewhere right now I've got councillor
Harker and heard councillor Harker these
reports do come to SAR and this is a
takeover bid by PGI the these these
reports it was quite clear that counsels
decisions or reports for noting are
placed in the members room and then
they're inserted on the agenda of SNR
and if a member wants to query anything
on the report it can be brought up at
SNR and we've had this discussion some
time ago with the director and it was
agreed that these reports would go
ah we had to be careful here because
we're starting to fiddle around with
operational issues we said no in our
remit particularly asking for exit
interview staffers workable that's
covered by the data protection so we're
in danger of getting ourselves confused
and making a complete mess I think if
the report should still go to SNR thank
you thank you for that I think the
leader might wish to raise an issue here
leader Kevin aye aye aye I'll give wait
and the monitoring officer chair because
I see he's got his hand raised but I was
all I was going to say is that my
exception reports on staff statistics do
go to committees for notes mr. cross yes
thanks very much chairman would it be
better in these circumstances because
there obviously is an issue about the
terms of reference and also an issue as
to if statistics are to go to a
committee which committee today did they
go to as that sounds to me to be the
issue now not whether they go to a
committee but to which committee they go
would it be better therefore that a
report comes back to okay a subsequent
council meeting dealing with this
particular point if members are saying
they want the information to go to a
committee that then we can look at sort
of rather in the cool of the day what
the terms of reference are exactly of
each committee and the remit of each
committee and come back to Council with
information yeah that sounds reasonable
I'll just I'll just asked for the I've
got three more councilors wish to speak
before I ask the leader what he thinks
of your suggestion councilor hood Thank
You chairman I've done wishes think I
was merely trying to
canvass the views of other members the
sound quality is very poor for me thank
you okay
councillor Chandler did you want to come
back well thank you chairman Justice I
did second the leaders proposal so there
is a proposal on the table chair
councillor settle that Thank You
chairman one of the things that I
looking at this is if you look at the
names of the committee's strategies and
resources is to do with resourcing human
resources is a resource to do with
staffing so logically to me the right
place for this probably I agree with
with their counselor Harker to me yay my
views it still comes to strategy
resources because we are dealing with
resourcing issues at that particular
committee but I go with you
mr. Crowley in fact perhaps we need to
look at this in more detail and that
enough and a more detailed report come
back to see where it best fits oh thank
you I think that concludes everybody Oh
Cal so Maurice wishes to state
councillor Morris just a quick note I do
believe it would be better if we had
more information than not enough so
whatever information the councillors
have asked for they should be supplied
with thank you well I don't think that
they were trying to stop anybody getting
the information leader would you like to
sum up your position please
okay chairman well clearly clearly there
is some concern whether this should go
to stay at a sauna or it should stay at
or it should go to PG a I actually think
we need to take a look and another look
at this chairman and I would propose
that recommendation one is revised and
it says that members do want statistics
all staff statistics including exiting
news reported to the relevant committee
and the corporate governance working
group chairman takes a takes a look at
this and reports back to Council to
decide which committee it should go to
and then we can look at process we can
get this right I don't know if anybody
be prepared to second that but it makes
it yeah you know I just point out you
don't need to redraw the motion that
you've already speaking to well withdraw
I think because okay they say no okay
you know I think so basically it's a
referral back and I think it's is a
referral back but making it absolutely
clear that we want all of this
information reported to committees I
hear the argument about exit interviews
but we used to get that information they
were done in summary and I think to be
honest you know if it was obviously the
person was maybe that wasn't reported
because gdpr is important to abide by
but I think that's perhaps where we
should go and I think that the corporate
governance working groups probably do to
meet soon anyway if not we can have a
meeting and then we could we can kick
this about on Ben Lomond right that's
proposed and duly seconded
do members agree that this is referred
to corporate governance working group
yes that shall be so we've been move on
to agenda item 11 which if I can catch
myself up
supplementary estimates environments and
use of reserves to the 39 2019 to the
31st of May 20 20 pound on pages one
seven five two one seven eight leader
can I just declare that I made one of
these environments I authorized one of
the violence as the purse is an interest
thank you no okay well likewise but
that's mentioned in recall and chairman
this this is very much what it is so I
would propose chairman that we agree
both recommendations thank you is that a
second did
yes yes yes any distinct can I say
that's agreed by acclimation weed he was
on page 176 under item number 3 it said
external investigation of complaints
budget approved by council fluke remark
on the third of the third oh three the
interest needs to be may be typed a typo
there sir okay thanks for that but
generally by acclamation that
recommendation is carried agree agenda
item 12 patrols and enforcement found on
pages 179 to 195 leader please yeah
Thank You chairman I think most of us
know the history of this this is
basically changing their budget and
saving some money and going into to
partnership with the police so that we
can we can deliver on our statutory
obligation to enforce on the river black
water Kevin there is a couple of
questions have been raised whether or
not there should be a service level
agreement all a Memorandum of
Understanding and my understanding is is
because the proposed partnership is
non-financial ie more than District
Council of not paying a consideration
for a six police ride the service an MOU
is better term of agreement as opposed
to a service level agreement the council
and the police are two statutory bodies
as well who should be working together
and that MOU allows for both parties to
to do that for mutual benefit and of
course should either party not meet of
the MOU the other parts you can exit the
contract with no with no legal
consequences so chairman and you know we
do need to enforce on the river is
getting a bit of the problem chairman
I'll uh I'll give way to I was going to
give way to the officers anyway before
I wanted to clear up at that point and
then I'll come back to deal with the
recommendations thank you okay Thank You
mr. Holmes to kick off good afternoon
mr. chairman members I'm quite happy to
to take any questions on this if you
like I think first of all what we need
to accept is that the police approached
the council based on the success of our
previous a personal watercraft team and
it's taken a while to get to this get
this far there was a false start where
their management decided at sort of the
11th hour last time that they were they
they weren't prepared or they didn't
have the resources to undertake this and
actually it was quite fortuitous that
they did they contacted us when when
they actually did this time rather than
us go out and buy rebut and then they
contact us so what they're actually
doing is in offering us this partnership
working is they're offering us a place
at their table and I'm not just talking
about simply enforcement using personal
watercraft what we also have is a
dedicated police officer for the river
Blackwater so if there are any issues
whatsoever we can go straight to him and
he will provide us a targeted response
that officer is also one of a very small
number of drone operators for Essex
Police and in my discussions with them
they have offered that as a resource as
well as land-based
assets as well Thank You mr. Harlan mr.
Wilson did you wish to add anything
you're muted Matt I am
I apologize no no chairman there nothing
further to add to the report detail
thanks very much I've questions
councillor Swain and councillor Logan
counselor Swain
thank you gentlemen just a couple of
points and where would these two PwC's
be stationed and secondly is there some
special training that people need
particularly if they're going to be sort
of additional backup officers the that
the PwC's would be based at probably
Burnham or at Boram airfield which is
where they keep all their motor vehicles
as far as training goes yes that the
police do have their own RA affiliated
training establishment but certainly all
of the officers that would be using it
would need to meet their criteria as
well as any national criteria as well
Thank You councillor laggin I think it's
here I was just interested really
because we haven't been that successful
in PwC's in the past history also
there's a large statement about there
that we could increase the prosecution's
that we would have to fund those
prosecution's the District Council what
what previous level of prosecution and
income did that bring to the council and
what do you think because obviously I
might get that that we do have a serious
challenge on the river that's speeding
and anti-social behavior etc etc but
what sort of benefit will this bring
rather than the presence will we
actually see a financial return to us
well firstly I should explain that with
all bylaws the money goes directly to
the crown who are the main holders of
the the main legislation and a bylaw is
just a derivation of that that main body
of
of legislation so all of the income
would go to would go to the crown
having said that we could put in and I'm
sure mr. gross would be happy to to
expand on this the costs we would be
awarded to the council so certainly we
couldn't look at it as a money-making
scheme but we could certainly look at it
as covering its costs Thank You mr.
Harmon leader Thank You chairman
chairman I I would propose therefore
having having listened to mr. Harmon and
his words being echoed by mr. Wilson
what members said I think chairman we
should agree the greedy recommendations
and move forward this as quickly as
possible so to echo council Agins word
that we you know we deal with these
speeding vessels and an anti-social
behavior on the river as quickly as
possible thank you chairman and I so
propose is that seconded yes please
thank you very much I'm sorry it's very
very bad very bad reception here I think
I I think I heard from mr. Harmon that
it could be kept at Borum he said
correct yes he said that he said or
possibly boring so okay my question then
my question is how quickly can we expect
a response and how exclusive is our
access to it please I thought you've
covered that mr. Howe no but please try
and help mr. Hurd yes yes of course mr.
chairman and the the response would be
it's probably along the same line
as had they been owned by solely owned
by Malden District Council if there is
an issue afloat then if the if the
machines are afloat at that time then it
would be quite rapid however if let's
say they were based at the depot at the
parks department as the old ones used to
be then you're probably looking at a
couple of hours before we could actually
get on site to to start taking some
enforcement action having said that the
police do have those other assets so
they have the drone if necessary and
they also have the land assets so if we
could say that there was a problem let's
say let's say a launching ramp in in
Malin C then a land asset would get
there an awful lot quicker and start to
take action Thank You mr. broke my rules
in allowing another question after the
proposal had been put but I think the
recommendation has been put and has
seconded so therefore is there any
dissent to this no the motion is carried
and we move on to agenda item 13 which
is rather a strange one so if we move on
can I just confirm that members of green
recommendations now this is a strange
one amend agenda item 13 amendment to
minutes
detailed on page four of the agenda for
the reasons outlined leader would you
like to explain well I'm not quite sure
why this is how it came to us but
clearly there was a mistake in the
minutes and they were approved by
members so I think we're trying to
unravel that chairman so I would propose
that we agree to amend the minutes
who's that second it yes I heard was
that you want a question I think that
sorry carry on sorry sorry I'll leave
that is that I'm on the wrong on the
wrong go oh sorry
okay I think we've I think again Tara we
had put this question and there's been
no dissent so its acclamation again
great question football team questions
of the leader of the council in
accordance with procedure rule on 3m any
member wish to ask the question of the
leader one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
there are none I'll move on to agenda
item 15 business by reason of special
circumstances considered by the Chairman
to be a function does thing to ever be
working of a sky teacher saw it a few
times and no one gets back to me I wish
to ask the question
oh you're gracious thank you I'd just
like to ask counsel felucca that if as
expected the disgraceful decision that
was reached at his joint standards
committee where he admitted to
homophobia bullying and fretts if it's
found that that has been a predetermined
decision and has brought the council
into disrepute will those counselors be
encouraged by himself to step down from
all committees to save any further loss
of reputation to modern district counsel
I don't leader I don't know whether you
wish to answer that question which I
would certain
Chairman I will I will respond of course
I mean following the meeting of Council
on the 23rd of June on the Sargen a
report is coming to the next council
meeting regards to the joint standards
committee where the new joint standards
committee is going to be formed and that
will be a matter that the joint
standards committee will consider going
forward once we get them once we get the
johnstons committee in place all of
those comments that you've made will be
taken into constant into consideration
to joint status meeting and they will
make recommendations accordingly but I
can't comment on the work of the joint
standards committee but one thing is
sure we are planning to move all of
these issues forward as quickly as we
possibly can chairman thank you thank
you very much we then go on to 15
business by reason the special
circumstance is considered by the
Chairman to be urgent I have none we go
on to agenda item 16 which is exclusion
of the public and press and I will make
the proposition we're now moving to
private session and I move that under
section 184 the Local Government Act
1972 the public impress be excluded from
the meeting during the consideration of
the following item of business on the
grounds that it involves the lightly
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph 3 of part 1 of
schedule 12a to the act and that this
satisfies the public interest test in
relation to the later contracts and is
that seconded second ad carry is that
agreed yeah we read Tara has the live
link been severed yet but you please
confirm when it has 7 I'm just
confirming that for you I keep your
moment